-And now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"How I Got Dumped"
stories from you guys.
Here we go. This first one's
from @kyleosmon.
He said...
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
It's like, "What's going on?"
-Wake up!
-This ones from @ItsNotTheFall.
"It's not the fall"?
Is that a famous thing?
It's not --
It's not the fall.
Talking about seasons?
[ Laughter ]
It's not the fall that hurts...
-The coffee?
The bunk?
The rehab?
[ Laughter ]
It's not the fall,
it's the rehab.
-I'm thinking skiing.
I'm thinking skiing.
-Oh, I was thinking
falling from grace, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, you were thinking
fall from grace.
-Yeah, like, you know,
you hit rock bottom,
you have to go to rehab.
Something like that, whatever.
[ Laughter ]
-Everything okay, man?
-Nah.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sleeping on my couch
in the office.
-We'll talk about this later.
We shouldn't say this --
shouldn't do it
on national television.
This is from @ItsNotTheFall.
She -- She says...
[ Audience groans ]
[ Wah-wah! ]
-Oh, come on!
-It's not the fall.
-Yeah, not the fall.
-Holy moly.
If that ever happened...
Wow, wow, wow.
This one's from @notglue.
[ Laughter ]
-Not the fall and not glue.
-Not glue.
that's not glue, dude.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
Andrew Karn.
[ Laughter ]
-He says...
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-"I had nothing to do --"
-There's other stuff going on.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @matadorchick.
-Ooh.
Nice. No bull.
-She likes matadors.
-Yeah.
-She says...
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-That's it.
-Well, folks,
that's the ball game.
-Lates.
-[ Chuckles ]
This one's from @Ash10G.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Wow!
Wow!
♪♪♪♪
Wow.
-Ouch!
-This last one's
from @kalsimanmeet.
He says...
There you have it!
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.